[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tout bon jour à tous je suis
très ravi d'être parmi vous
que signifie vivre sa vie est ce que
vous vivez votre vie et qu'est-ce que
cela signifie
est-ce que la première femme française
européenne claudie haigneré qui est
parti dans l'espace peut-elle répondre à
cette question ou bien le célèbre
publicitaire jacques séguéla ou bien
d'autres choses encore philippe lucas
yann arthus bertrand jean louis etienne
où le pionnier de la greffe du foie
karim boudjema
et bien ces personnalités je les ai
rencontrés
pas avec un carnet d'adressés garni
davance
j'ai simplement faire un coup de fil et
ils m'ont répondu
les rencontres c'est très important dans
la vie des rencontres on vit aujourd'hui
dans un monde hyper connecté ou pour moi
c'est beaucoup plus simple d'aller vers
l'autre mais à deux conditions il faut
le vouloir et s'en donner les moyens
et vous est ce que vous vivez votre rêve
et qui voulez vous rencontrer
et à 6 ans j'ai rencontré un monsieur
qui s'appelle ghassan nkabari 69 ans
dans une gare
et je veux je le voyais faire des
figures extraordinaire équilibre sur
demande sur un skate mans
je sais pas s'il ya des fans de dragon
ball z dans le dans les parages mais
pour moi c'était tortue géniale quoi
j'étais fasciné comme le personnage
depuis on s'entraînait dans la même
salle de sport et j'ai vu toute la toute
l'émotion qui suscitait autour de lui
parce que ghassene c'est quelqu'un qui
partage quelqu'un de généreux
et là je me suis dit tiens
interview le et dont c'était la première
personne que j'ai terminé
depuis je me suis dit il existe
certainement d'autres ghassan quoi
imprégné de cette même énergie
de vouloir transmettre aujourd'hui six
ans après j'interviens plus de 500
personnalités
donc le créateur du jeu du docteur
maboule john spinello le chef pâtissier
de la maison blanche bill hay ocs le
champion du monde de pizza thierry graff
à dinho un gaz encore la vice doyenne de
l'humanité se rendraient qui aujourd'hui
118 ans
ya de la marge
donc la question c'est comment j'ai fait
et qu'est ce que j'ai appris de ces
rencontres
et d'un tout d'abord je me suis posé
cette question quelles sont les
personnalités de l'ombre qui ont
contribué à notre société
vous avez tous quelque part prêté j'ai
peut-être pour venir et aujourd'hui ou
peut-être repartir tout à l'heure où
demain eh ben je me suis dit qui a
inventé le tgv quoi eh ben ce monsieur
c'était jacques conteneurs attendons
j'ai mal fait mais la zapette jacques
houpert donc jacques cooper c'est lui
qui a 10 design et fait le tgv
est ce à dire que ce monsieur était pour
moi quelqu'un qui m'a beaucoup inspiré
l'une des versions de l'équipe m'a posé
la question d'ailleurs quelle est la
personnalité qui t'a le plus inspiré
alors c'était très difficile de répondre
à cette question donc mais jacques
cooper fait partie des personnes qui
vont beaucoup beaucoup inspiré c'est
quelqu'un qui ne calcule pas très
généreux comme ghassan et c'était un peu
que par un grand père pour moi
aussi j'ai aussi consulter les pages
blanches j'ai rencontré l'un des plus
grands professeurs de théâtre qui a eu
comme élève fabrice luchini il avait lu
pertes gérard depardieu jean laurent
cochet
pareil
un coup de fil
je les ai rencontrés
mais encore il suffit parfois juste une
petite attention un jour je suis allongé
la télé allumée et j'entends monsieur
par lee un commentateur et j'étais
tellement subjugué par son énergie par
sa vibration je me suis dit mais c'est
qui se garent en fait qui parle
et
j'ai trouvé j'ai cherché philippe
croizon alors qui est philippe croizon
c'est une personne qui a perdu l'usagé
de ses quatre membres et qui a traversé
la manche à la nage
puis relier les cinq continents il a
fait paris dakar et aujourd'hui il a
l'intention d'aller dans l'espace avec
elon musk
waouh quoi quand j'ai des crampes je
pense toujours à lui quoi je me dis
voilà atteindra 10 q squatter fatigue et
à d'écran tu te plains daf un nom n'a
pas le droit
donc c'est une personne aussi qui m'a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup inspiré
il faut savoir aussi c'est que aussi
j'ai dormi avec deux alligators et un
qui cobras chez phillip gillet célèbre
herpétologue
donc pareil là bas j'avais peur des
serpents
et là philippe me balance un alligator
tranquille
c'est totalement surréaliste on dirait
mais c'est une coupe je passais une
peluche quoi eh ben non c'est bien ça
j'ai aussi vécu des anecdotes assez
incroyable avec un monsieur qui a dormi
chez moi pendant trois jours jean
béliveau alors qui est jean béliveau
c'est une personne qui a traversé les
tous les continents il a fait le tour du
monde à pied pendant 11 ans 11 ans à
pied quoi 1500 familles il a rencontré
nelson mandela qui lui a dit un jour
jean il faut plus de gens comme toi sur
terre
waouh quoi nelson mandela
et là je me suis dit il faut que
j'interviewe ce monsieur mais comment
donc messieurs habite au canada et lui
me dit gens achètent pas l'argent pour
venir te voir je suis désolé comment
faire et moi j'étais inquiète pas genre
je vais trouver un moyen toi tu as fait
le tour du monde à pied pendant 11 ans
moi j'ai passé quelques coups de fil et
je vais te faire venir
donc qu'est ce que j'ai fait est un
festival à accepter du coup de le faire
venir et j'étais trop contente de voir
la défense quoi je dis voilà jean tu
vois on a réussi
donc il est venu avec sa femme et on a
passé trois jours dans mon petit studio
voit à nous raconter des histoires et
tous et moi je n'étais pas regarder ses
pieds quoi toujours chez des furets ses
pieds pour ils ont fait le tour du monde
quoi
enfin bref
aussi autre anecdote alors les a
beaucoup personnes en j'ai fait une
soirée avec alain duverne créateur des
guignols après l'interview jeudi alain
faudrait qu'on fasse une soirée avec des
personnes que j'ai interviewés et qu on
les réunit tous ensemble dit ok on va
faire ça sans une sorte de tedx quelque
part mais dans un appartement
et là on a passé un moment fabuleux avec
une vingtaine de personnalités et là il
ya un moment comme aujourd'hui de
silence où chacun écouter l'un et
l'autre enfin c'était vraiment très
c'était magique quoi elle avait un
respect
ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que
pourquoi ces personnalités ont honte il
a cité aussi de me rencontrer
et ben en fait foi cette fois même
simplement alors ça paraît bateau de
dire ça
mais il faut aussi montrer sa vue ni
enfin qu'on est faible en fait pendant
qu'on est comment dire faut pas cacher
en fait moi j'ai souvent fait selon dit
allah je suis venu j'avais pas beaucoup
d'argent donc j'ai pris le bus pour
venir vous voir et la personne en fait
elle est touchée en fait par votre
parcours votre discours est en fait ça
ça lui rappelle lui quoi où elle a ses
débuts
autres autre anecdote michel anglade
pilote d'hélicoptère il eu comme élève
yann arthus bertrand reconnaît pour ses
vues en photos aériennes lui mairéad arc
il aurait mis julienne et en jour on se
pointe chez lui
rené clément leroy quintuple champion du
monde en équilibre recorman du monde en
est qu'il ne restait plus que 24 heures
sur un vélo puis de 24 heures soit
environ des conseils
et donc michel
fait en sorte que clément pilote
l'hélicoptère
et là évidemment ans clémence et par un
pilote d'hélicoptère elle a bon climat
vous imaginer quoi l'hélicoptère qui
comme ça moi j'étais en panique un faut
dire la vérité michel cool ce rang est
là en fait il m'a appris un truc michel
que le plus grand le plus grand tard
c'était pas de connaître son art mais
c'était savoir la transmettre avoir
confiance en l'autre donc là ça m'a
beaucoup beaucoup aussi inspiré
aussi il faut savoir que toutes ces
aventures j'ai dit tout à l'heure je les
ai faits en vue bus et donc j'ai été
voir un monsieur
tong koné airbus mais qu'il a créée quoi
ils sont trois au départ donc j'étais
parti à lausanne je fais paris lausanne
en bus pour aller voir roger bétail donc
roger bétail confondateur d'airbus
et lorsque je lui raconte un peu mon
histoire me croyais que j'étais venu en
train en avion enfin bref normal quoi et
je le raconte je dis voilà monsieur
bétail je suis très honoré de vous
rencontrer
quand vous êtes venus en bus
et la salle a touché parce qu'en fait
c'est dit waow ce jeune ce jeune gamin
en fait et vient me voir m'interviewer
et s'intéresse à ma vie en fait est là
bas on a passé un moment fabuleux il m'a
raconté l'histoire d'airbus ils ont
commencé à quatre au départ c'est devenu
c'est devenu
aussi il faut savoir c'est que
un nom n'est pas forcément un nom
définitif
parfois on vous dit non aujourd'hui ça
veut pas dire que ces noms jusqu'à la
fin de votre vie quoi
je revenais à monsieur cochet le fameux
professeur de théâtre qu'est ce qui
s'est passé
j'ai acheté un de ses livres et dans son
livre il cherchait un poème d'henri pec
hélas il n'a jamais retrouvé ce poème en
fait depuis des années et moi j'ai eu
l'idée de faire un livre en fait
imprimer ce fameux poème et j'ai trouvé
sur internet et lui offrir le jour de
son anniversaire le 13 janvier
parfait qu'est ce que je vais faire je
me pointe chez lui à 10 heures du matin
13 janvier et je lui dis monsieur cochet
tenez cheville anniversaire et là il me
dit mais il a emmené par où est le sens
il me rappelle et ça l'a vraiment touché
1 et il me dit voilà on a theme
justement été touché par votre votre
geste qu'on a même étudié
les pointes d'henry becque rythme est
élevé
quelque temps plus tard bas ont fait
l'interview il m'a fallu attendre quatre
ans
quatre ans pour pouvoir l'interviewer
donc voilà
ce qu'il faut savoir aussi
c'est que même un refus c'est pas grave
en fait moi j'ai voulu interviewer un
astrophysicien et il m'a répondu m'a dit
ben non je vais pas t'entendre je vais
pas être interviewé peint par toi parce
que tous les gens que tu a interviewé
n'ont aucun lien avec moi moi je pensais
que les étoiles les planètes tout ça
tout est interconnecté inquiets pas de
frontières et tout est là j'ai une idée
je me suis dit mais
attends je vais pas le l'un des plus
connus en fait et là j'ai eu l'idée
d'interviewer hubert-reeves
ibérique m'appelle monsieur qui tu iras
tu ok pour l'interview rendez vous chez
moi
c'est ça la magie en fait vous inversez
le
l'énergie il m'a reçu chez lui en
chaussettes chaussettes colorées
est-ce que c'était génial c'est qu'en
fait c'était plus lui qui me posaient
des questions
et la voilà c'est des moments comme ça
que qui m'ont beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
marqué
la personne après
pour finir qu'est ce que j'ai appris de
ces rencontres
est bien quelque part ces rencontres va
toutes ces personnalités me ressemblait
par leur timidité par leur courage leur
pugnacité
leur sensibilité qu'au delà du rêve j'ai
découvert quelque chose de fabuleux qui
est l inattendu l'inattendu quoi
je pense à cette phrase de laëtitia
guinée ou ambassadrice l'oréal coiffure
que j'ai interviewé je suis une
éternelle apprentis on n'en finit pas
d'apprendre la curiosité
au départ quand j'ai été voir ces
personnalités je me suis dit bon bah tu
vas être rassurés en allant les voir
mais c'est pas du tout le cas en fait
j'ai toujours peur et même en allant les
voir j'ai toujours peur est en fait faut
avancer avec center et qui a pas de bon
ou de mauvais moments je pense à cette
phrase de philippe croizon qui avait dit
un jour
j'ai d'abord une idée ensuite j'ai les
informations j'ai peur mais c'est trop
tard l'aventuré lancée et ça c'est mais
aussi restée gravée dans la tête
donc il est bien beau de voir des ponts
mais traverser les c'est encore mieux
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]